bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est
sens public votre rendez-vous de débat
et de reportage on est ensemble tous les
jours à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat vous
le savez pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos invités experts
nos chroniurs et nos éditorialistes et
voici le sommaire de ce 16 janvier le
rendez-vous avec la nation annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron en décembre passe donc
par le Tami des questions des
journalistes conférence de presse
annoncée comme XXL ce soir à l'Élysée à
partir de 20h15 vous pouvez la suivre en
direct sur notre antenne évidemment le
président qui doit répondre au
principale préoccupation des Français
pouvoir d'achat en tête mais aussi à la
polémique oua castaira qui freine les
premiers pas du nouveau gouvernement on
sera en duplexe de l'Élysée évidemment
avec tamtranui et puis on posera les
limites et les enjeux de ce face-àface
médiatique avec nos expert dans une
minute autre rendez-vous dans notre
émission les vœux de Gérard Larché le
président du ce sera vers 19h20 au per
avant on se posera la question de
l'avenir et de la stratégie du parti LR
les républicain après l'entrée de Rachid
hadti au gouvernement Rashid adati a
fait un choix
elle assume et elle en connaissait les
conséquences je lui avais dit
ministres sur 14 sont membres d'anciens
membres de LR comment se démarquer dans
un tel contexte politique comment éviter
aussi un nouvel échec électorale lors
des européennes dans moins de 6 mois
réponse dans TR qu4 d'heure mais d'abord
donc cette conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron critiqué par ses
opposants avant même d'avoir commencé
Fabien
RER voilà des semaines qu'Emmanuel
Macron annoncer un rendez-vous avec les
Français celui-ci prendra la forme d'une
conférence de presse en prime time au
programme des 20h15 un propos liminaire
d'une vingtaine de minutes le chef de
l'État devrait faire plusieurs annonces
au plus près des préoccupations passion
des Français promet l'Élysée comme la
santé l'éducation ou le pouvoir d'achat
Emmanuel Macron répondra ensuite aux
questions de la centaine de journalistes
accrédité et aux interrogations sur les
premiers pas du gouvernement àal déjà
englué dans une polémique visant la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale un
gouvernement accusé jusque dans les
rangs macronistes de pencher trop à
droite un mois après le vote de la très
controversée loi immigration le
président de la République devra
préciser son cap pour la fin de son
quinquena les oppositions dénoncent déjà
la forme et n'attendent rien du fond
sinon un grand numéro comme quoi il a
repris la main comme quoi il garde la
main comme quoi il gardeera la main
Macron a du mal à accepter l'idée que
fin du 2uxè quinquena sera extrêmement
difficile c'est le retour de l' RTF quoi
hein parce que 20h15 c'est l'heure des
foyers c'est l'heure du foyer on se
retrouve on mange il s'impose dans tous
les foyers français ça va être le grand
chaud Macron à cette occasion donc sur
l' for moi je suis assez c'est perplexe
un exercice très solennel auquel le chef
de l'État ne s'était plus livré depuis
avril 2019 il tentait alors de s'exirper
de la crise des gilets jaunes
Emmanuel Macron va-t-il sauver le soldat
ouea Castera c'est l'un des thèmes l'une
des grandes questions l'un des enjeux de
cette conférence de presse il y en a
beaucoup d'autres et on les aborde tout
de suite avec mes invités nos invités
franc Morel bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
avocat associé chez flichi Granger
ancien cons social d'Édouard Philippe
amatignon et de plusieurs ministres et
experts à à l'Institut Montaigne lors
Salvin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice générale des études verriant
excantard public Bastien François
bonsoir et bienvenue professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université
parisen Panthéon Sorbonne et puis
signale votre livre qui vient de
paraître retrouver Estelle mouflage aux
édition galimar vous êtes parti sur les
traces d'une adolescente victime de la
Choa peut-être qu'on aura le temps d'en
dire un moi à la toute fin de ce débat
je l'espère en tout cas Émilie zapski
bonsoir et bienvenue Émilie spécialiste
en communication politique on a
particulièrement besoin de vous ce soir
et éditorialiste pour pour sens public
alors je vais faire un tout petit retour
en arrière tiens parce que je suis sûr
que l'un des mots sur lequel Emmanuel
Macron va être interrogé là dans dans
dans dans les prochaines heures c'est ce
réarmement réarmement du pays l'avait
utilisé lors de ses vœux que vous
inspire ce choix sémantique Fran il est
très signifiant ce choix sémantique et
du reste je le rapprocherai également
des termes qu'a utilisé le président de
la République lors du premier Conseil
des ministres postraniment puisqu'il a
parlé de de révolutionnaire et d'action
hein donc le la sémantique est guerrière
elle est une sémantique d'action et on
voit bien que le sens qui est donné à ce
ranimement c'est un sens consistant à
revenir à un certain nombre pas tous
mais un certain nombre des fondamentaux
de 2017 et notamment les fondamentaux
liés au au mouvement au fait d'engager
des réformes de faire bouger les choses
mais est-ce que c'est pas dire on
revient au fondamentaux de 2017 est-ce
que c'est pas paradoxal alors qu'on a
quand même le sentiment que plus on va
en chaque nouveau gouvernement nommé par
Emmanuel Macron se droitise d'une
certaine fa c'est pour ça que j'ai dis
pas tous effectivement se lié à l'action
mais effectivement vous l'avez souligné
à juste titre le remaniement marque
aussi un rééquilibrage plutôt vers la
droite par rapport au précédent
gouvernement d'une manière plus générale
je crois qu'il faut aussi mettre ça en
perspective avec une grande constante de
la 5e République qui est la suivante
quand vous regardez les différents
mandats des différents présidents de la
républque vous avez toujours un premier
Premier ministre du mandat qui est le
fruit d'un équilibre politique d'un
message politique d'un un allié ou d'un
message politique lié aux conditions de
l'élection Jacques Chirac en 74 Michel
Rocard en 1988 par exemple et le second
Premier ministre est traditionnellement
un homme ou une femme du président
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui est plutôt
are exemple
V alors le second Premier ministre du
second c'estàd voilà Gabriel atthal
coche les deux cases en même temps
c'est-à-dire c'est à la fois un proche
du président de la République et puis
c'est à la fois quelqu'un qui envoie un
message politique un peu qui se veut
disruptif alors on pense à à mitteran
qui nomme it cresson avec les faits la
première fois qu'une femme est nommée à
Matignon ou Fabius déjà les fait jeune
en en 198
et donc derrière ça le message politique
c'est à la fois je nomme quelqu'un qui
est proche de moi comme
traditionnellement dans la 5e République
le deè Premier ministre effectivement
après la première séquence très
politique mais je veux aussi envoyer un
message à travers jeunèe du PM d'action
le mot action on y reviendra évidemment
je reste sur réarmement l Salvin est-ce
que en utilisant ce terme Emmanuel
Macron répond aussi à une demande
finalement exprimée par une partie
importante des Français d'ordre d'ordre
républicain hein je pense
qu'effectivement il y a clairement un
message guerrier qui est qui est donné
avec le la nomination de ce de ce
gouvernement et je pense qu'il ressemble
à aucun autre de ces précédents
gouvernements donc pour le coup moi je
suis pas tout à fait sur un retour à
2016 je pense que c'est quelque chose de
complètement nouveau qu'il souhaite
entamer je pense que quand il pense à
guerre je pense qu'il pense à campagne
électorale notamment il pense
à 2024 je pense aussi qu'il pense à
municipal de 2026 et puis évidemment
présidenti 2027 donc là pour moi c'est
vraiment une séquence complètement
différente à laquelle il a jamais eu
affire vous avez une autre guerrière
aussi qui a été nommée c'est Rachid adti
voilà qui est en tout cas perçu par les
Français comme une vérit présente elle
aussi comme ça tout à fait donc
effectivement voilà je sais pas si c'est
c'est ça dépasse l'action en fait pour
moi c'est vraiment un combat politique
qu'il souhait mener a priori contre le
RN parce que c'est quand même ça euh son
son sujet et son cheval de de bataille
donc je pense que c'est un gouvernement
très politique et peut-être beaucoup
moins tourné vers l'action très concrète
pour les pour les Français enfin voilà
alors ça c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on
verra aussi avec cette conférence de
presse ça va être l'un des enjeux à
priori mais ça on le verra avec
tamtranui un peu plus tard ça devrait
quand même occuper on va dire le le
premier tiers de cette conférence de
presse justement les préoccupation
majeure des euh des des des Français
peut-être on peut basculer justement
Bastien François sur pas encore sur la
forme de la conférence de presse on y
viendra un peu plus tard mais sur le
fond c'est quoi d'après vous l'enjeu
principal pour Emmanuel Macron ce soir
bah justement c'est peut-être de donner
un sens à à ce terme parce que moi
franchement la question que je me pose
c'est serait armé contre qui h alors
même que nous sortons d'une séquence
quand même incroyablement
conflictuelle il y a eu les retraites il
y a eu la loi immigration bon alors je
je veux bien qu'il a en qu'il a en face
de lui qu'il veut monter un gouvernement
de combat contre contre le RN dans la
perspective des européennes mais se
réarmer contre qui et alors et même dans
le même temps avec quels alliés pour
combattre quoi parce que là on discute
on parle d'un remanement pour moi c'est
plus qu'un remanement he c'est un
changement de Premier ministre et donc
c'est un changement de gouvernementou
mais
euh se battre avec qui et pourquoi avec
qui là la question n'est pas du tout
réglée pour le moment c'est pas parce
que vous prenez Rachid Dati que ça va
changer les équilibres et à la rigueur
même ça risque d'affaiblir son aile
gauche ça même ça risque même on le voit
ça hérite un petit peu ses alliés de
horizon de de du moderne bon donc il y a
quelque chose d'assez curieux donc voilà
il va peut-être nous expliquer ce soir
alors c'est un petit peu étonnant qu'il
nous l'explique comme ça maintenant il
aurait pu nous l'expliquer il y a qu'un
jour hein bon au moment où il changit de
Premier ministre parce qu'il a pas
vraiment justifié le choix de de de
changer de Premier ministre euh et donc
voilà c'est c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
attend et c'est peut-être parce qu'il a
créé cette attente là qui qui qui fait
un un grand barnom ce soir pour pour
mettre conférence de presse XXL ce sont
les termes des communiquants de l'Élysée
je suis assez d'accord avec vous on se
demande ce que ça veut dire en fait
est-ce que ça peut vouloir dire chez les
Français qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
c'est un réarmement civil moi
franchement je sais pas très bien
répondre à ça qu'est-ce que c'est un
réarmement économique bon on peut un peu
plus imaginer un renforcement de la
France sur le plan économique mais c'est
très vague c'est très abstrait c'est
très abstrait et ça correspond au
vocabulaire et la rhétorique habituelle
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est dans le
concept et pas du tout dans le concret
comme vous le disiez mais ça correspond
aussi à une rhétorique qui appartient
plus à la droite il me semble et ce
gouvernement je trouve qu'il ressemble
plus à un gouvernement de droite
qu'auparavant et je suis d'accord avec
vous ça ressemble pas tellement à 2017
c'est beaucoup plus accès à droite il a
senti que ce besoin de fermeté on l'a vu
avec laaba l'uniforme des choses comme
ça c'était souhaité par les Français
c'était accueilli vraiment favorablement
ces mesureslà et quelque part le
réarmement ça rentre dans la même le
même type de rhétorique autorité
réarmement voyez quelque chose d'assez
ferme alors sur le fond je demand des
réponses assez courtesil y a plein de
thèmes à à aborder sur sur le fond de
cette conférence de presse commence avec
vous lors Salvin euh s'il doit répondre
en français c'est sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est là-dessus qu'on l'attend
prioritairement c'est évident oui je
crois que Y a y a pas de sujet là-dessus
il y a pas d'ambigué entre deux ou trois
sujets prioritaires pour les Français il
y en a un c'est le pouvoir d'achat dans
toutes les conversations effectivement
dans des Français il y a ce pouvoir
d'achat qui revient dans les premiers
premier mot cité donc effectivement ça
va être compliqué pour lui d'éviter le
sujet il y a deux sujet notamment très
de proximité he il y a un le le prix de
l'électricité qui va augmenter
normalement au 1er février est-ce est-ce
peut annoncer un report ou pas
effectivement ça c'est un vrai sujet et
puis on en parle aussi depuis un moment
sur le logement il y a absolument rien
qui n'a été fait en tout cas aux yeux
des Français
depuis depuis 2017
quasiment depuis 2000 voilà donc là sur
ce sujet-là c'est vraiment des
préoccupations très concrètes pour les
Français l'électricité le prix de
l'électricité et le prix du logement et
la capacité à se loger avec les on a
fait un débat là-dessus hier qui était
passionnant avec un effet domino depuis
évidemment les constructions dans le
neuf jusqu'au location puisque tout tout
toute la chaîne se se tarie alors
pouvoir d'achat restons làdessus
peut-être avec avec vous Franck
Morel a je cherche l'équation parce que
comment annoncer des mesures pour
favoriser le pouvoir d'achat des
Français quand on est face à un mur de
dette de 3000 milliards d'euros
absolument c'est tout évident bien sûr
euh le président de la République a
parlé de réarmement économique et
réarmement civique donc on voit bien que
c'est les deux grandes têtes de chapitre
et le pouvoir d'achat est dans la
première des deux dans le réarmement
économique alors après effectivement on
imagine mal le président de la
République faire des chèqus c'est-à-dire
annoncer des des rallonges en direction
de tel ou tel type de public même de
manière justifiée et donc on va être
plutôt dans l'incitation c'est-à-dire on
va être dans tout un tas de dispositifs
vraisemblablement qui incite à à apporté
une réponse la plus pertinente possible
à cette thématique du pouvoir de l'achat
mais je suis d'accord avec vous il y a
pas en la matière de formule magiquein
ça saurait si on avait une disposition
qui permettait demain matin d'augmenter
massivement le pouvoir d'achat de
l'ensemble des de l'ensemble de nos on
en croit Bruno lomère il a rangé le
chéquier tout au fond tout au fond du
tiroir je voudrais qu'on parle
maintenant un peu de la forme et du
timing de cette conférence de presse on
va je vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant mini mais d'abord on se tourne
et je crois qu'elle est prête je la vois
ici euh dans le froid parisien vers Tam
tranui qui est en direct dans la cour de
l'Élysée bonsoir Tam je sais que vous
êtes très très bien équipé pour passer
cette soirée d'abord dehors puis à
l'intérieur éventuellement poser une
question au président peut-être un mot
du dispositif annoncé pour commencer et
oui j'ai j'ai sorti les chaussettes de
ski pour suivre Emmanuel Macron même si
son objectif est sans doute plutôt de
réchauffer ses relation avec les
Français ce soir et cela par
l'intermédiaire Thomas des journalistes
entre 200 et 300 journalistes sont
attendus il faut dire que les occasions
sont rares pour les médias de se rendre
à l'Élysée pour vous le disiez cette
grande conférence de presse XXL la
dernière elle date de 2019 et faisait
suite à la crise des gilets jaunes et
tous les médias seront donc bien sûr
représentés nationaux presse quotidienes
régional télé radio presse écrite web
correspondants étrangers l'élsée entend
bien répartir la parole entre tous ces
médias alors dans la salle des fêes il y
aura bien sûr tous ces journalistes mais
aussi le gouvernement Atal le Premier
ministre avec ses 12 ministres et trois
ministres délégués mais c'est bien sûr
la parole du président de la République
que l'on attend avant tout le président
de la République qui devrait s'exprimer
en premier avec des propos liminire
d'une vingtaine de minutes et on nous
annonce des propos concrets on nous
annonce des annonces justement adressés
aux Français pour et bien détailler ce
réarmement économique et civique ça
devrait porter sur l'éducation la la
santé ou encore le pouvoir d'achat et
ensuite et bien cette conférence de
presse doit se séparer en trois parties
distinctes une partie préparée comme un
rebond à ces annonces concrètes du
président de la République ensuite une
deuxième partie sur la vie publique et
la vie politique c'est là qu'il y aura
les questions plus politiques sur le
remanimement ou encore bien sûr la
polémique Amélie ouéa casterra et enfin
une troisème partie qui sera elle
consacrée aux questions internationales
l'ensemble doit durer entre 2h et 2h30
mais avec Emmanuel Macron vous le savez
comme moi et bien les délais sont
souvent dépassés bref la nuit au moins
la soirée s'annonce longue oui merci
beaucoup Tam et et à tout à l'heure
parce qu'il y a a aussi le jeu des
questions des journalistes et je vous
demanderis de nous expliquer comment ça
va se passer dans un court instant
j'espère que vous pourvez vous
réchauffer un petit peu d'ici là euh à
tout à l'heure évidemment on vous fera
vivre en direct cette conférence de
presse d'Emmanuel Macron sur nos nos
chaînes parlementaires Miriam ankawaa
sera à mes côtés
tout à l'heure on prendra l'antenne une
petite demi-heure avant 20h15 pour poser
les enjeux redire des choses qu'on aura
dit ici et puis ensuite pour débriefer
l'intervention présidentielle Bastien
François Le le le président qui choisit
de convoquer la presse là comme
ça avant le discours de politique
générale du du Premier ministre comment
vous l'analysez il y a une façon simple
dire c'est un mauvais signne pour la
marge de manœuvre de Gabriel àal on peut
peut-être aller plus loin aussi comment
vous l'analysez bon il y a deux choses
d'abord on en revient classique de la 5e
République parce que vous êtes très
jeune mais République ça a quand même
commencé avec des grandes conférences de
presse le général de GA le gouvernement
à un mtre en dessous de lui enfin et
cetera donc c'est c'est même un peu
étonnant parce que c'est c'est presque
une forme un petit peu reingarde hein
c'estàd que par rapport aux facilités
qu'accorde la télévision les réseaux
sociaux tout ça là on revient à quelque
chose de très solennel Patrick caner le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
disait dans le sujet d'ouverture retour
à l' RTF non mais bon non je dirais pas
ça mais mais c'est vrai que c'est une
forme de je dirais historique de mise en
scène de de la prééminence
présidentielle donc là on est dans
l'affirmation vraiment claire de la
prééminence présidentielle et on voit
dans la scénographie le gouvernement la
masse des journalistes et puis voilà le
président qui joue à domicile les
conseillers qui font passer des petits
messages avant au journalistes attention
là là il y a une mauvaise humeur ce soir
en ça ça c'est ça c'est la première
partie mon avis c'est c'est c'est pas
choisi tout à fait par hasard ce format
le bon s'agissant du président de la
République et du Premier ministre ben en
réalité on est dans la continuité de
quelque chose qui a commencé Emmanuel
Macron qui avait commencé d'autres
présidents avant mais qui qu'il a
tendance à pousser hein c'est-à-dire
à mettre plus qu'avant sous sous
contrôle un premier ministre ça passait
par le fait que par exemple
Emmanuel Macron avait décidé de partager
un certain nombre de ses conseillers
avec avec matigon h pas laèreis
président de la républqueitte de
déclaration deque générale avant la
décation detique générale de son de son
premier ministre on l' connu ça va
rappeler un souvenir à Fran Morel mais
je vais vous demander de nous raconter
de l'intérieur dans un instant même fait
si mes souvenirs sont bons un discours
devant le Congrès le jour précédent bon
donc là c'était énorme bon là c'est
forme moins solennelle mais voilà il est
clair que Emmanuel Macron a décidé
d'avoir un Premier ministre qui serait
un collaborateur pour parlerorse comment
ça se passe juillet 2017 Édouard
Philippe a été nommé à matigon vous
faites partie de son cabinet vous êtes
l'un de ses conseillers j'imagine la
tête que vous avez vu faire quand vous
avez appris que le président convoquait
le Parlement en congrès à Versailles
mais comme vous l'avez dit c'est un
grand classique de la 5 mais il un grand
classique accentué par le
quinenaou vous avez raison de souligner
le le rituel de la conférence de presse
on a en tête les images du général de
Gaulle avec André Maller avec George
Pidou mais effectivement depuis euh la
réduction du mandat présidentiel de 7
ans à 5 ans la prééminence du président
s'est affirmée avec plus de force alors
évidemment vous faites référence à cette
à cette cet élément historique hein avec
la convocation du Congrès la veille du
discours de de politique générale c'est
un signal il faut le prendre comme tel
évidemment et c'est un signal qui est
envoyé qui doit être décrypté comme le
président reste le le boss reste le
patron dans le système de la 5e
République euh et il entend
jouer ce rôle de patron complètement il
a cassé une chaise Édouard Philippe
quand il a appris ça c'est quelqu'un de
bien élevé qui n'a pas cassé de chaise
mais effectivement l'ensemble des
équipes ont pris ce on pris ce signal
comme tel ce qui est bien ce qui est
bien logique ce qui est bien normal et
vous connaissez les règle du jeu
d'ailleurs d'entrée de jeu quand vous
dans dans les relations entre le
Président de la République et le Premier
ministre et encore plus j'ai envie de
dire dans dans un contexte de début de
quinquena où le président veut aussi
marquer son territoire euh et marquer sa
prééminence en envoyant un certain
nombre de signes ou et puis on était
dans la présidence jupiterrienne on
souvient le Louvre comme première image
Versaille assez vite tout ça cadré y
a-t-il une attente des Français pour
cette parole présidentielle on va
discuter de ça tout de suite et avant de
vous entendre sur sur ce thème on écoute
Sébastien Chenu le le vice-président du
rassemblement national bon forcément
négatif le président de la République
nous a déjà habitué à ces formats nous
dit sur une conférence de presse XXL
assez superlatif qui à la fin ne
débouche sur rien moi je me souviens et
je garde un mauvais souvenir des débats
des gilets jaunes on disait c'est des
heures de débats il a parlé de tout et à
la fin que reste-t-il de tout cela rien
donc non nous n'attendons rien mais je
crois que les Français n'attendent pas
grand-chose du président de la
République euh est-ce qu'elle est
vraiment démonétisée je c'est la parole
présidentielle ou alors au contraire
revitaliser dans l'attente des Français
hein c'est c'est vraiment là-dessus par
la nomination de Gabriel Atal je pense
que quand même il y a une petite attente
de compréhension et de sens
effectivement à la nomination de de de
ce nouveau gouvernement et de Gabriel
Attal l'intérêt pour la politique des
Français il n'a ce qui est quand même
assez marquant il n'a pas baissé depuis
1 an
depuis enfin 1 an et demi maintenant
depuis les élections présidentielles et
législatives normalement après une
séquence électorale l'intérêt pour la
politique et pour pour l'actualité
politique baisse normalement là de
depuis un an et demi finalement elle a
pas baissé donc quand même il y a une
attente de la part des Français de
savoir ce que ça va donner savoir ce que
Emmanuel Macron va pouvoir aussi
inventer c'est c'est c'est là où les
enjeux sont très importants pour lui
c'est-à-dire que quand même malgré tout
on attend beaucoup de choses et si
effectivement il annonce pas grand-chose
ça va être très déceptif et je
reviendrai juste sur la forme le fait
que ce soit devant les les journalistes
et ça rejoint le combat je pense que il
dit aussi moi je je dois mener un combat
et j'ai besoin de vous les journalistes
donc c'est pas tant un appel au français
ou une conversation avec les Français
qu'avec un vrai message auprès des alors
justement Ilie ce format conférence de
presse pas très habituel pour le
Président on peut dire non alors moi
j'ai compté auparavant deux conférences
de presse on parlait de celle de 2019
pour les gilets jaunes vous vous
souvenez le grand conclusion du grand
débat il y avait aussi 2021 pour la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne donc c'est vraiment les deux
seuls exercices il préfèrent les
allocution plus formelle sans
contradiction de l'Élysée en direct ou
préenregistré les présidents juste avant
lui alors on parlait on en parlait
Hollande et Sarkozi c'était pas beaucoup
plus fan du format à l'inverse de Gaulle
17 conférences en 10 ans Pompidou
mitteran était bien plus Friant cette
fois-ci Emmanuel Macron quand même il
mouille sa chemise il y va il est temps
pour lui d'annoncer ce grand rendez-vous
avec la nation qu' le prévoit depuis
plusieurs semaines et peut-être on peut
le souhaiter donner aussi enfin le cap
de ce quinquena qui peinene à démarrer
alors puisquon est sur la forme le
l'horaire ce choix n'est pas àodin 20h15
avec diffusion sur Public Sénat
évidemment sur les chaînes d'information
aussi certains et vous avez parlé de
Patrick canner annonce le retour de l'
RF parce que globalement il va être
partout en même temps on est loin du 13h
sur France 2 ettaf1 qu'avait organisé le
président là on était en mars 2023 pour
la réforme des retraites donc qui était
beaucoup plus ciblé ou alors les
interviews dans la presse quotidienne
régionale là il veut toucher le plus
grand nombre quitte à saturer he comme
je disais l'espace médiatique et ça il
sa'est faire saturer l'espace médiatique
on se souvient des heures de diffusion
durant le grand débat national mais
c'éit l'après-midi he c'était
l'après-midi ça débordait parfois sur la
soirée c'était sur les chaînes d'info en
fait ça donnait au chaînes d'info aussi
un du contenu qui coûit pas très cher
disons les choses mais au fil du temps
quand même elles ont un petit peu limité
la casse he on peut-être pas tout
diffuser RA il y avait aussi les visites
au salon d'agriculture je crois qu'il y
avait eu 14 heur une fois étaient
suivies pareil alors quel impact ça peut
avoir bah c'est là le point le plus
épineux parce queon sent bien
qu'Emmanuel Macron il cherche à se
réinventer à nous surprendre euh on sait
qu'il le fait souvent et il y arrive
grand débat j'en parlais mais il y avait
aussi convention citoyenne Conseil
national de la refondation les
rencontres de Saint-Denis mais bon le
problème c'est qu'au fil du temps ces
surprises elles ressemblent un peu à des
gadgets qui sont pas toujours suivies
même quasiment jamais de décisions
fortes qui sont capables d'embarquer la
nation et puis il y a une impression de
déjà vu les Français connaissent un peu
ça donc gare à l'effet déceptif quel
contenu pour cette conférence quelles
annonces il peut faire alors que on le
sait il est toujours empêché par cette
majorité qui est de plus en plus rela et
parlons encore du timing est-ce qu'elle
arrive à un mauvais moment pour vous
cette confence al oui ça devait être un
peu un point culminant après après ses
vœux parce qu'il avait déjà parlé de
remanement civique économique après le
remanement même s'il est pas encore
terminé mais ça tombe un peu mal côté
calendrier alors le lancement de ce
nouveau jeune premier ministre a été
très réussi ça a démarré en grande pompe
ou mais bon il y a eu cet accident avec
la polémique autour de desbire d'osé
Amélie oua casterra Hué encore ce matin
à l'école litr puisquelle est tourné
donc le contexte est pas tout à fait
favorable pour cette conférence on y
revient dans un instant sur cette
polémique Amélie ou ou DEA Castera mais
mais quand même je voudrais rester sur
le fonctionnement de ce duo exécutif
Bastien François avec vous puisque on a
appris cet après-midi ce ce mardi aprèsm
la déclaration de politique générale de
Gabriel hatal aura lieu le 30 janvier ce
qui est quand même tard est-ce que ça
vous a surpris ça moi ce qui me me
surprend à vrai dire c'est le c'est
c'est c'est le déroulé c'est qu'on a un
PR ministre on attend quand même 3 ou 4
jours pour
avoir le début d'un gouvernement qu'on
appelle gouvernement resserré mais qui
en réalité un gouvernement un peu obèse
c'est dire on voit tout su bah parce que
personne peut est capable tout seul de
gérer des des des des des des
portefeuilles de cette taille là on voit
bien en plus qu'il manque quand même
dans la liste des choses assez
élémentaires hein le logement les
transports et cetera bon donc on se dit
évidemment bon les minist déléés ou é V
AR voilà bah j'espère hein parce que
sinon il y a des ministres qui vont un
peu souffrir
euh on a cette conférence de presse on
va on nous dit qu'on va attendre encore
une peut-être une dizaine de jours pour
avoir le le le le gouvernement au
complet ce qui est quand même
incroyablement long j'ai jamais vu ça
dans l'histoire de la 5e République et
ce qui m'étonne c'est que je me dis
quand même que le Président de la
République il a quand même réfléchi ça
fait quand même un certain temps qu'il
réfléchit à changer son gouvernement
c'est assez étonnant que les choses se
fassent à ce rythme là et je crois que
ça brouille d'ailleurs le message je
suis pas certain que ça soit une très
bonne image parce qu'on voit pas pour le
moment on voit pas le programme c'est
qu'on a un gouvernement on sait pas à
quoi il sert alors on le saura peut-être
ce soir oui j'allais c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire euh là il y a deux
rendez-vous là la conférence de presse
dans dans dans dans quelques heures et
puis ensuite la déclaration de Politien
là on aura un peu plus de de précision
sur le cap quoi ça ça met quand même du
temps pour donner le cap alors même que
euh on sait qu'on est enfin tout le
monde est conscient du fait qu'on on on
on doit aborder des sujet extrêmement
compliqué je sans même évoquer parce que
vous savez que c'est un peu monada les
questions de transition écologique mais
la question du logement on continue à
perdre on continue à perdre un mois la
question des transports là aussi c'est
des enjeux absolument considérable de de
de structuration du territoire
d'investissement et cetera bon la les
questions d'énergie et ceter voyez c'est
qu'on a l'impression que ça voilà on
prend son temps et ça c'est quand même
un petit peu surprenant ouais en
écoutant les questions au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi Franck Morel
bon on a retrouvé un un Gabriel Atal
voilà efficace et très bon communicquant
ça il y a pas de surprise et il l'
vraiment mais je trouvais ça un peu
particulier je me disais que ça va durer
alors au moins une semaine de plus de
d'être dans cet exercice sans avoir déjà
fait son discours de politique générale
c'est il fait référence sans qu'on sache
exactement ce qu'il y a dedans et ça
est-ce que ça le place pas un peu comme
ça en porte à fau on est un peu dans
dans l'entre deux je pense que ce soir
est un moment important par rapport aux
grands axes qui vont être donnés par le
Président de la République et qui va
permettre de de compléter le le dernier
étage en terme de sens que ce que vous
soullignez tout à l'heure hein qui
manque à ce changement de Premier
ministre et à ce remanement c'est-à-dire
il va donner concrètement en tout cas on
l'espère hein et en tout cas c'est sans
doute ce qui ce qui est prévu euh un
contenu à ce fameux réarmement
économique et réarmement civique et
s'agissant du Premier ministre ben il
faut qu'il trouve sa place dans ce cadre
là et je trouve intéressant
effectivement l'information que vous
venz de donné sur la date un peu plus
lointaine du discours de politique
générale parce que effectivement ça va
permettre au Premier ministre dans la
confection de ce discours de politique
générale de prendre en considération de
manière beaucoup plus approfondie les
grands axes qui auront été posés ce soir
et puis sans doute la liste plus
complète du gouvernement et donc les
correctifs éventuels c'est qu' son
discours politique général avec un
gouvernement avec un gouvernement
complet c'est-à-dire avec les quelques
correctifs éventuels en direction
notamment des alliés du MoDem de horizon
sur les portefeuilles ministériels et
sur une vision vraiment achevée on va
dire en terme de contenu de du
gouvernement pH vous connaissez bien et
le président du MoDem François baayrou
très silencieux depuis depuis quelques
jours parce que il joue le coup d'après
he c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer on verra oui d'accord on a bien
compris ça veut dire ça veut dire oui il
vont faire en sorte que ça ser
rééquilibre avec avec les prochains
ministres alors le le cas Amélie oua
casterra vous y avez fait référence
quelques secondes on va y consacrer du
temps parce qu'évidemment ça se
complique ou en tout cas ça ne se règle
pas aussi vite je l'imagine que Gabriel
Atal l'espérer on en parle tout de suite
avec Jonathan
duprieèz bonsoir Jonathan bienvenue à
vous on pourrait presque dire que la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale a
remis une pièce dans la machine
aujourd'hui ouais c'est complètement ça
Thomas éteindre la polémique ou la faire
repartir pour un petit tour de piste
Amélie oua casteral a un peu joué son
vatou si l' peut dire en se rendant dans
l'ex école de son fils l'école litré à
Paris pour je cite s'entretenir avec les
équipes pédagogiques Amélie oua Castera
elle est arrivé visage fermé ce matin
sous un concert de casserole d'une
trentaine de personnes écoutez pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ambianceent
donc voilà hein vous prenez un peu la
température hein ce déplacement avait
donc pour but quand même de faire taire
définitivement la polémique dans
laquelle AM ou Castera est en train de
de s'engluer depuis son premier
déplacement en tant que ministre pour
mémoire face aux caméras c'était
vendredi dernier elle avait avoué retiré
avoir retiré son fils aîné du public
pour le mettre dans le privé au prétexte
je site d'un paquet d'heure de cours pas
sérieusement remplacé des propos qui ont
été vécus comme une véritable
provocation
é desong et donc ce matin elle a
présenté ses excuses à sa sortie de
l'école
[Applaudissements]
écoutezation revenir
sures excuses que je leur devais de les
avoir blessé j'ai pu aussi rvoquer le
fait que je regrett de les avoir cit
nément j'ai d'ailleurs à cur qu'il
puisse
vraiment voilà être un peu épargné de de
tout ça et travailler dans la sérénité
qui soit préservé bon quand on va
essayer les images on a clairement le
sentiment que ça va pas suffire à
éteindre cette incendie qui met qui
place le gouvernement àal en difficulté
en P effectivement c'est un premier qui
Thomas qui contrarie vraiment les plans
de de l'exécutif à l'heure où Gabriel
Atal voulait insuffler sans doute un
vent nouveau sur le le quinquen
d'Emmanuel Macron et vouloir du résultat
rapidement hier il y avait dans un
article des échos des propos de Gabriel
T qui se disait fort agacé par ces
sorties non maîtrisé de sa ministre hein
qu'il entend désormais jeelcide coach
qu'il entend coacher et la situation
semble aussi s'envenimer d'autant que
c'est ces propos de la ministre sont
arrivés un moment très tendu avec le
monde enseignant et avec une grève qui
se profile et donc on on a l'impression
que ça va raviver cette fameuse grève
des enseignants du 1er février et donc
cette position finalement de la ministre
àarît de plus en plus intenable et par
de il y a aussi les oppositions
politiques qui qui en profit qui s dans
la brèche et surtout à gauche qui
pilonne la ministre l'accusant notamment
de mépris de classe voire même de
séparatisme scolaire et donc les appels
à la démission se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours et encore ce matin
écoutez Mathilde Panau il y a la
polémique très forte autour de la
nouvelle ministre de l'éducation qui
compte aussi l'éducation mais aussi la
jeunesse mais aussi les Jeux Olympiques
les Jeux paralympiques madame oua
Castera ça je laisserai Rodrigo Arenas
en parler en tout cas pour nous il est
évident que cette ministre ne peut pas
rester et qu'il n'est pas possible
d'abîmer l'école publique pour justifier
un choix personnel d'autant plus en
méprisant autant le personnel de
l'éducation celles et ceux qui font
vivre l'école de la République voilà
Thomas et vous en parliez en début de
tranche évidemment tous les regards se
tournent maintenant sur la conférence de
presse d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir
qu'est-ce qu'il peut dire va-t-il
recadrer va-t-il peut-être débarquer sa
ministre peu probable mais en tout cas
une chose est sûr c'est que améie ou
Castera est plutôt sur à merci beaucoup
Jonathan et à très vite on vous retrouve
pour notre second débat tout à l'heure
consacré au parti LR les républicains I
Je je me tourne vers vous vers la
spécialiste en communication politique
est-ce que c'est pas alors il y a deux
lectures je vous laisser faire la vôre
mais quand même une erreur de
communication de voilà de relancer la
machine médiatique en allant dans cette
dans cette école ancienne école de de
son fils oui je pense que c'est la
deuxième erreur parce que la l'erreur
initiale c'est d'avoir parlé au-delà de
sa situation personnelle d'avoir jugé en
fait d'avoir commencé à parler des
professeurs critiquer le public alors
qu'on le demandait pas parce que les
Français sont très respectueux du choix
public privé elle aurait pu couper cours
deuxème erreur donc en effet de revenir
sur les lieux du crime j'allais dire
pour essayer de s'expliquer de s'excuser
vous avez entendu c'est terrible moi ça
m'a fait penser à la réforme des
retraites au cassrelad on avait oublié
ça et tout d'un coup on revient avec des
espèces ça a ouvert la voix à des
revendication qui n'était pas tellement
audible dans la sphère publique des
enseignants de l'école publique ça a
complètement ouvert ça donc ça dépasse
le cadre de sa propre situation là pour
le coup elle a vraiment ouvert les Vanes
je pense que c'était une erreur il
fallait essayer plutôt de tourner la
pageu considérer que enfin voilà
elle va au bout elle P elle P elle va à
Canosa elle purge les excuses elle purge
jus elle elle est engluée dans cette
crise c'est de plus en plus grave parce
que ça va vraiment du côté de l'école
publique et plus seulement de sa
situation personnelle on a entendu
gabrielal tout de suite essayer de
déminer le truc et je pense que il était
furieux qu'elle puisse utilis cet
argument là c'est très dur pour lui de
déminer ça et moi je dirais c'est
peut-être la difficulté de gabrielal ça
va être de tenir ces ministres parce que
au-delà de cette ministre qui a été très
mal à droite il y a des ministres des
poids lourds quand même qui ont déjà eu
des propos un petit peu embêtants je
pense à géraldin qui a dit moi après les
j globalement c'est ce qu'on a compris
moi après les j j'ai fini ilait annoncé
luime gouvernement
il ce gouvernement il est là pour le
combat des élections européennes il est
là en intérim comment il va tenir ces
ministres là on sent bien qu'il va faire
attention ti leà restons merciie sur le
cas Amélie Castera forcément interpellé
lors des questions gouvernement à
l'assemblé cet après-midi voici sa
réponse sil voust je n'aurais pas dû me
laisser entraîner sur le terrain de la
vie
privée ni me sentir obligé de me
justifier aucun parent d'élèves ne
devrait l'être et je n'aurais pas dû non
plus exposer l'école
litrée je suis allée à leur rencontre ce
matin pour m'en excuser et m'excuser de
les avoir blessés ces excuses je les
leur devais euh Franck Morel quelle
réponse Emmanuel Macron peut-il apporter
ce soir sur ce sujet oui forcément la
soutenir très attentif sur la manière
dont il va la soutenir parce qu'il va
sans doute la soutenir mais il y a
plusieurs manières de soutenir il y a
soutenir comme l'Accord de soutient le
pendu où il y a vraiment soutenir on va
voir effectivement ce qui est certain
c'est que la difficulté vous vous vous
l'avez dit est d'autant plus
éclatante que on ne peut s'empêcher de
mettre ce qui s'est passé en en regard
en comparaison avec la manière dont
Gabriel Atal lui-même quand il avait été
nommé ministre de l'Éducation avait tout
de suite déminé le sujet de l'École
alsacienne oui puisque c'est il avait
lui fait sa scolarité avait dit dans
lors de la passation de pouvoir
c'est-à-dire il avait pris les devant
avant même que quiconque n'aille sur ce
terrain-là en se situant sur un terrain
uniquement personnel et la difficulté
dans cette affaire c'est que
contrairement malheureusement à ce que
ce qu'a dit la ministre dans les
questions au Gouvernement c'est pas le
problème personnel qui est en cause
c'est le fait d'avoir mis en regard
d'une situation évidemment personnelle
qui évidemment ne pose aucune difficulté
un sujet de Fond un sujet de fond qui
prenait à rebour les enseignants et les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
donc toute la difficulté elle est là et
je crois que pour sortir de ça il faut
arriver à aller sur un autre terrain à
mettre en perspective la question sur un
autre terrain et c'est sans doute ce que
va essayer de faire ce soir le président
de la République ou alors c'est d'autant
plus dommageable en fait je trouve que
c'est pour moi c'est une vraie crise
politique c'est pas juste effectivement
anecdotique comme ça peut-être le cas de
certains co classe c'est d'autant plus
dommageable que
l'éducation c'était une des priorités
affichées de d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
aussi pour cette raisonlà selon lui
qu'il a nommé Gabriel hatal au poste de
Premier minist Gabriel qui dit j'emmène
avec moi le lesation et je pense que
pour la conférence de presse de ce soir
c'est ce qui était prévu c'était aussi
de faire remonter l'éducation parce que
comme on le disait tout à l'heure sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est très difficile de
euh d'agir donc une des stratégies
d'Emmanuel Macron pourrait être de dire
oui il y a des problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat mais moi je fais remonter aussi
à notre sujet et l'éducation et et les
Français le prendront l'éducation aussi
pourquoi parce que c'est un vrai sujet
aussi de de préoccupation donc je pense
que je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron doit
être très très embassé à l'heure
actuelle pour savoir effectivement s'il
continue à mettre le focus sur
l'éducation ou pas et puis je pense
qu'en terme d'opinion c'est TER ble
aussi parce que ça renforce l'idée qu'il
y a une vraie fracture entre les élites
les hommes politiques les femmes
politiques et les
Français comme comme nous d'ailleurs
Gabriel hatal dans ses traits d'images
là qu'on commence à regarder on voit que
la proximité avec les Français fait
partie de ses principales faiblesses
ouverture au dialogue certes capacité à
décider oui mais proximité avec les
Français c'est le dernier item et je
pense que ce min ce gouvernement risque
d'être francilien aussi dans ce
gouvernement très très très peu de
régions françaises représenté alors que
c'est plus difficile quand on a un
gouvernement resseré forcément mais
quand même comme emblème de du 7e
arrondissement de Paris tout le monde
voilà donc effectivement cette fracture
entre la réalité que vivent les Français
et c'est pour ça que vous disiez Émilie
les castrolades mais il y a aussi les
gilets jaunes sont pas si loin que ça en
fait hein ils sont pas complètement
enterrés et là le risque c'est vraiment
que la polémique et et la crise sociale
remonte en France le le le l'un des
syndicat le syndicat national des agents
publics de l'éducation nationale a
déposé plainte ce mardi c'est l'une des
infos du jour pour diffamation contre
Amélie oua Castera bon la la la spirale
négative là on est en plein dedans
Bastien François est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer on a parlé du de de de la
deuxème vague la seconde vague de de
nomination finalement un un ministre ou
une ministre un peu poids lourd ministre
délégué un peu poids lourd à l'éducation
qui finalement viderait cette partie du
du Marocain de de d'Amélie ou caster
serait un peu bizarre hein quand même ce
serait pas ce sera l'accord qui se mais
c'est vrai que là la difficulté pour le
président de la République est est est
très grande il s'est présenté il y a
quelques mois comme mettant l'éducation
nationale dans son domaine réservé je
crois que c'est la première fois qu'un
président de la République mettait
l'éducation nationale dans ce qu'on
appelle le domaine réservé qui est
quelque chose qui n'existe pas
juridiquement mais qui est
symboliquement très très
important monsieur monsieur hatal avec
quand même réussi l'exploit avec pas
grand-chose avec la baaya avec des
discours sur l'autorité les les
connaissance à faire oublier que la
rentrée quand même avait été de
l'éducation nationale en septembre avait
été extrêmement difficile vraiment
extrêmement difficile en terme de
présence d'enseignants dans ch Paron a
toujours un souci majeur d'attractivité
les concours ne trouvent pas
suffisamment de Candat là vous avez une
ministre qui invente un argument parce
qu'on sait très bien que cet argument
n'a pas été le bon argument ce n'est pas
n'était pas l'argument qui lui a fait
changer d'école ses enfants ce qu'on a
appris depuis en tout cas il y a deux
témoignages qui qui la contisentû et euh
euh et ressort ce problème qui n'est pas
réglé en réalité qui est le problème de
de l'absence d'enseignant devant le bon
problème que connaissent beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de parents d'élèves
bon euh partout hein y compris dans le
privé bon et là tout d'un coup on se
rend compte que bah oui ça fait quand
même 7 ans que que Monsieur Macron est
président de la République on a eu un
grand ministre soi-disant monsieur
Blanquer qui allait tout régler mais qui
n'a pas réglé ce problème là on l'a pas
vu à la rentrée parce que c'est cétait
passé un peu sous le tout du pass-p du
du jeune ministre qui qui qui qui
réinvente qui réinvente l'école et tout
d'un coup la question de l'école arrive
vraiment dans sa difficulté majeure
parce que ça il suffit pas de plaquer
dans les doigts pour avoir des Pres dev
il semble qu'il y a un décalage qui se
fait aussi sur ces questions là et pas
que sur l'éducation sur la santé aussi
sur l'hôpital
déétait beaucoup de communication Gabri
qui voulait essayer de répondre à tout
et on voyait bien que ce gouvernement
qui est tout nouveau mais qui hérite de
ce bilan de 7 ans ne peut pas répondre à
des questions très concrètes des
Français il manque de on manque de
soignant ça fait quand même longtemps on
manque de médecin à l'hôpital est tabou
et pareil côté éducation une espèce de
décalage entre la grand la communication
grand grandiloquante et puis des
préoccupations concrètes des Français
qui ne sont pas qui ne trouvent pas de
réponse au niveau du gouvernement un mot
là-dessus et puis ensuite on retourne à
l'Élysée pour pour avoir quelques
détails sur la façon dont les questions
seront posées au au président avec Tam
tranui non moi je par rapport à
questionation par rapport à la question
des préoccupations concrètes je voudrais
rebondir
là-dessus il y a quelque chose qu' qu' a
choisi de faire le le nouveau Premier
ministre qui va être compliqué à à tenir
dans la durée c'est le fait de faire un
déplacement par jour ou et on voit bien
que derrière cette volonté de faire un
déplacement par jour il y a la volonté
d'être dans précisément dans le concret
parce que c'est quand on fait des
déplacements quand un ministre ou un
premier ministre fait des déplacements
qu'il va être précisément confronté à
des interrogations concrètes de ceux de
nos concitoyens qu'il va rencontrer et
on va avoir d'ailleurs souvent
l'occasion d'avoir un certain nombre
d'images des échanges sur des sujets
très pratiques qui vont en résulter et
donc on voit bien que derrière ça
derrière ce souhait de faire un
déplacement par jour il y a précisément
le souhait d'être si vous me permettez
l'expression les les pieds dans la
glaise he voilà et et et d'être au
contact à porté d'anguelade comme on dit
parfois àorté d'engueelade de de de nos
concitoyens mais effectivement ça ça
peut fonctionner si derrière on a une
batterie de mesure un certain nombre de
de d'évolutions qui sont annoncées et
qui peuvent outiller précisément ces
échanges nourr lors des déplacements et
donc c'est c'est ça qui qui va qui va
falloir regarder qui va falloir observer
alors alors on repart à l'Élysée comme
promis avec Tam tranui qui est toujours
en direct Tam comment ça se passe
j'imine vous avez prévu votre votre
question pour le président évidemment
mais comment sont choisis désigner les
journalistes qui vont pouvoir intervenir
oui alors effectivement Thomas j'ai
prévu une question pour le président de
la République et pour cela et bien j'ai
contacté l'un des attachés de presse de
l'élisé et Thomas j'ai une confidence à
vous faire et bien je ne suis pas la
seule he parmi les 250 300 journalistes
qui sont attendus ce soir et bien
nombreux se sont manifestés pour poser
leurs questions et ceux qui pourront
donc interroger directement le président
de la République feront partie des happy
few alors on est prié en tout cas de
dire et bien dans quel cadre s'intègre
notre question si on est plutôt dans des
questions rebond euh aux annonces du
président de la République si c'est une
question plus politique autour du
remanimement ou si c'est plutôt une
question de relations internationales
hein pour que et bien les attachés de
presse sache quand est-ce qu'ils peuvent
nous tendre le micro alors comment ça
devrait se passer cette séance de
questions et bien cela devrait d'abord
s'ouvrir par le président de
l'Association de la presse
présidentielle qui doit et bien ouvrir
le bal mais aussi faire un point de
méthode car tout le monde est prié de
faire cours les journalistes comme le
président de la République on nous a dit
pas de question à tiroir he plutôt des
questions direct et on Nimagine pas de
relance et le président aussi prévoit
lui-même de répondre de façon plutôt
brève car et bien on sait à quelle heure
s'intègre cette conférence de presse un
horaire où il y a beaucoup de monde
devant la télévision et l'idée ce n'est
pas de perdre des téléspectateurs ce
n'est pas de les lasser sachez enfin que
nous avons toutes nos chances puisque
c'est toujours le placement libre dans
la salle des fêtes six attachés de
presse qui sont remunis de micro
l'objectif sera bien sûr de se
manifester avec le plus de conviction
possible pour interroger le chef de
l'État tout à l'heure merci beaucoup Tam
TR pour toutes ces ces informations
c'est bastien François il y a toujours
est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment creuser un thème avec le
président dans un exercice comme
celui-là vous voyez ce que je veux dire
parce que un journaliste pose sa
question et en général il a envoyé le
thème effectivement Tam vient de nous
l'expliquer bon pas forcément la
question au mot près mais le thème et
puis derrière on lui reprend le micro il
y a pas vraiment de droit de suite et
souvent le confrère qui pose la question
suivante bah il est sur autre chose il
va pas voyez le challenger un peu le le
le président de la République sur ces
sur ces réponses est-ce que finalement
le risque d'un tel exercice n'est pas
défleurer plein de thématiques
différentes en fait tout dépend de la de
ce que veut faire le répondant en fait
oui c'est lui qui a la main mais c'est
lui qui a totalement la main et c'est
quand même des grands grands
professionnel donc c'est c'est des gens
qui sont capables rebondissant d'une
question à l'autre d'essayer de mettre
de la cohérence bon je pense que c'est
extraordinairement frustrant pour pour
les journalistes bien sûr pour les
citoyens d'ailleurs oui et c'est vrai
que c'est une particularité quand même
aussi des journalistes français les les
journalistes anglo-axant ils sont
beaucoup plus possifs pour dire non mais
vous avez toujours pas répondu à ma
question donc je vous repose la question
alors qu'en France si vous regardez la
plupart des interviews en principe il y
a une question qui est posé
éventuellement une relance mais très
vite on passe et on se souvient
notamment de des interviews de François
miteran où effectivement lanait un
regard glacial sur la moindre relance
effectivement le journaliste comprenait
très vite qu'il fallait qu'il s'arrête
immédiatement votre avis franc Morel sur
ce sur ce alors c'est pas un jeu hein il
y a on attend on attend beaucoup de de
de des réponses du du président de la
République mais bon voilà les
journalistes si on est choisi on essaie
quand même de de de de poser la bonne
question sauf qu'il y a pas toujours de
droit de suite mais je pense que le le
choix du format est aussi un message en
soi euh on parlait tout à l'heure des
grands rituels de la 5e République et le
choix d'un format qui va permettre de
dérouler des réponses sur un sur une
thématique donnée de manière un peu
complète sans précisément avoir l'aspect
relance effectivement et donc en en en
ayant la possibilité de le développer
complètement comme le président le
souhaite en terme d'angle de vue en
terme de de coup de projecteur plutôt
sur tel aspect que tel autre est
signifiant en soi c'est-à-dire c'est la
volonté effectivement de dérouler sur un
certain nombre de thématiques un message
global cohérent complet bis après c'est
vrai c'est un exercice un peu compliqué
parce que parfois on retient que un tout
petit truc d'une conférence de presse le
le célèbre Carla et moi c'est du sérieux
bon c'était une grande conférence de
presse déjà et finalement tout ce qu'il
a dit avant tout ce qu'il a dit après
n'a pas compté donc il y a aussi un
risque de dans la maîtrise de son propre
message c'est si on voilà si tout d'un
coup on est plus naturel ou qu'on répond
enfin je sais pas là il y a le risque
que toute la conférence de presse
disparaisse derrière une petite phrase
ouais maisski le président de la
République il va il va vouloir et on l'a
vu avec Tam on l'a évoqué aussi tout
àheure d'abord répondre aux
préoccupations des Français notamment
dans la première heure qui sera celle la
plus suivie parce qu'après il y aura
sans doute des chaînes privé qui
passeront à autre chose et cetera et
cetera bref donc donc c'est là qu'il
faut qu'il soit le plus efficace oui le
plus efficace le plus incisif on sait
qu'il est très bavard mais il fait
l'exercice depuis plusieurs vœux il
essaie de concentrer un peu de faire
plus court 10 minutes 15 minutes alors
qu'avant on avait toujours 20 25 30
minutes et puis j'en parlais tout à
l'heure des logoré indéfinis dans lequel
on se noit complètement où on retient
absolument pas mesures lui il il a
toujours envie de dire mais regardez
voilà ce qui se passe regardez ce qui se
passe voilà les objectifs que j'ai on le
sent bien dans toutes ces interventions
dernièrement il est un peu frustré de
voir que les Français n'arrivent pas à
imaginer tout ce qui se passe là il va
falloir au contraire je pense qu'il a
plusieurs thématiques mais pas beaucoup
si c'est l'éducation si c'est l'économie
si c'est le social économique il en
reste là avec quelques mesures pH en
tout cas moi en terme de communication
c'est ce qui est le plus efficace la
plupart du temps c'est moins de messages
parce que trop de messages ça noit
complètement le poisson et puis cette
expression con crte et là c'est
difficile aussi pour Emmanuel Macron je
le disais tout à l'heure il a souvent
des concepts ou des des mots un peu
qu'on nutilise plus qu'on comprend pas
très bien il fait l'effort de se
rapprocher quand même du vocabulaire des
uns et des autres mais c'est toujours
quelque chose de difficile pour lui et
il a un atout Gabriel lui il se fait
très bien comprendre il il est très
pédagogue je trouve il a toujour été
mais en tout cas ça peut l'aider dans la
déclinaison du message qu'il va porter
ce soir vous serez là dans tout à
l'heure parce qu'on va on va commenter
analyser avant et après la conférence de
presse et on va vous la proposer en
direct sur nos
évidemmentilap fera partie des des des
invités de de
ce desbriefing pardon de cet horrible
anglicisme qui qui m'est venu de la
conférence de presse d'Emmanuel Macron
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat basen François un mot de ce livre
pourquoi vous vous êtes parti sur les
traces d''estelle moufarge ben il y a il
y a une dizaine d'années je lisais le un
journal et je vois qu'il y a un site sur
Internet où qui dit où les enfants juifs
déportés ensuite ont été arrêtés
par curiosité je rentre dans mon
ordinateur je tape le nom de ma rue et
je tombe sur elle et en fait il y avait
très peu d'informations sur elle elle
habitait à à trois immeubles du mien et
donc j'ai fait une très très très très
longue enquête parce qu'en fait elle est
orpheline et cetera donc elle a laissé
très peu de traces et donc j'ai essayé
de reconstituer l'ensemble de sa vie de
de de sa naissance donc en 27 à à sa
mort à
en 43 merci beaucoup retrouver Estelle
moufar c'est donc le le titre de euh ce
livre que vous publiez aux éditions
galimar à bientôt sur sur ce plateau
merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat